this recipe is a Ramsey family
traditional Christmas Day smoked salmon
scrambled egg and cross on its rich
sumptuous and incredibly easy to do
first the croissants slice them into
rounds and season them lightly with
solvent that's the secret behind a
really good breakfast is in the timing
on the crystals on first smoked salmon
on top and then the scrambled egg put
the questions in a dry pan and toast
you don't need oil because the quasars
have a lot of butter in them this is a
great way to transform day-old
croissants giving them a delicious new
life just start to see them toasting
almost listening in the pan and that's
the butter inside as smell is amazing it
almost smells like a sort of caramelized
waffle absolutely delicious toast them
all around both sides and then out next
just get the smoked salmon and sort of
twist it and let it fall over the
Kressel let it sit naturally on top of
the toasted croissant
[Applause]
or twist and over right
scrambled eggs eggs into the pan never
whip up the egg beforehand you break
down the egg too much what I want to be
nice rich creamy scrambled egg eggs in
no seasoning at this stage a nice
generous knob of butter now from there
onto the heat and all you do now is stir
stir and stir and stir
[Music]
now the butters melting that has given a
really nice creamy texture to the eggs
it looks rich delicious sumptuous
luxurious if you're very careful making
scrambled eggs all of a sudden it looks
funny and within 30 seconds it's cooked
working it all the time right after
stirring a plastic scraper in there take
the pan off the heat and just work
around the pan cleaning up all that
scrambled egg that's sticking to the
bottom and now look we're getting that
really nice sort of creamy beautiful
texture little touch a butter in there
now I'm gonna start with the seasoning
30 seconds on the end
salt pepper back on to the stove and a
tablespoon of cream the cream actually
stops the scrambled egg from overcooking
cream in and then fold that in there now
keep that off the heat but look at it
look at that color beautiful
and then finally some fresh chives
[Music]
is around the classic smoked salmon
toasted croissant and a delicious
scrambled egg
the best start to Christmas Day anyone
could wish for
[Music]